in der bizarren feier der taliban dort
in der nähe von kabul paul was spielt
sich jetzt gerade bei dir ab
patricia ich bin hier noch immer mitten
unter den taliban die provinzfürsten
sozusagen der taliban sprechen gerade
und ich habe meinen übersetzer mal
aufschreiben lassen was sie hier gesagt
wir sehen und hören leider dass uns da
ganz kurz die schalte zusammengebrochen
ist völlig klar paul ist mitten in
afghanistan diese verbindung es
schwierig aufrecht zu erhalten wir
versuchen das natürlich hier in dieser
sendung immer immer weiter ja er ist in
novara aktuell ungefähr 100 km sagte er
von kabul entfernt ist dabei einer feier
die die taliban unabhängigkeitsfeier
nennen bei uns im studio nina schenk
allein dieser begriff ist schuldig wenn
ich euch und herren über freiwillig
nutzen um mit ban zu sprechen du bist
wieder da beim independence day dort in
wadern
du hast hier wir müssen ganz ruhig sein
ihr werden verschiedene auch koranverse
vorgelesen und wir sehen die ganz viele
klagen ja gesehen ganz viele taliban
kämpfer herum finden sie ihren gerade
gesagt in einer ihrer ansprachen haben
sie gesagt dass sie vom westen verlangt
dass sich niemand in ihre inneren
angelegenheiten
einmischt dass sie gutes systematischen
beziehung wollen aber das nicht hin mehr
einzumischen hat ich laufe noch mal ein
bisschen weiter
sehen wir die ganze masse der menschen
sehen wie viele tausende menschen sich
hier versammelt haben und übersetzte
noch einmal das was sie gerade gesagt
wurde ab sofort hier die scharia gilt
dass man das land besser machen wird
dass man insgesamt ja aufräumen wird
hier im land und es gibt viele
versprechungen der taliban fürsten sie
sagen sie werden gute beziehung mit dem
besten ausbauen man muss sich immer
wieder überlegen ist ja das sind ja
diejenigen die hier sitzen
neben mir sozusagen gegen die wir so
lange gekämpft haben das sind hier
unterwegs war in verschiedenen gebieten
zu landen und ich zeige euch noch einmal
4 die gesamte situation
alle drehen sich um alle schauen dich an
das selbst besonders leise sprechen dass
da nicht stören wie gefährlich schätzt
du die situation jetzt dort auch für
dich als reporter ein
da steht sie als geht hier jetzt nicht
um eine gefährdung sondern ich will
darüber berichten was hier passiert ich
habe gleich um mich herum die mich hier
ja sobald es geht ja halten uns wie
schon in den vorherigen schalten gesagt
habe die taliban haben gegen uns gegen
den westen gekommen und ich habe das
gefühl das wollen sie zeigen natürlich
ist das ein seltsames gefühl hier zu
sein und in die augen zu blicken
derjenigen gegen die der westen gekämpft
hat aber auf der anderen seite
des verhandlungstisches mit unserer
bundesregierung stehen vertriebs ja und
das ist die neue realität ob wir sie
wollen oder nicht wir sehen hier
und so was euch sicherlich aufgefallen
ist es gibt hier keine auf die kinder
die gekommen sind darunter vier jungen
die dabei sind
ganz banale frage paul wie trommeln sie
sich da alle innerhalb kurzer zeit
zusammen die haben auch alle neue fahnen
beispielsweise in der hand diese weißen
taliban flaggen wie organisieren sie
sich dass sie alle da wussten heute
kommen wir da in nevada zusammen und
machen so 0 abhängigkeit fest
das funktioniert hier durch die provinz
lieder sozusagen durch die gewinnst
fürsten die dann ihre leute versammeln
und die nicht dabei sind sozusagen die
menschen dann aus den dörfern auch
hierher mitzubringen das sind alles
kämpfer gewesen der taliban auch außen
rum um dieses feld dass es hoch
gesichert mit vielen tieren
militärfahrzeugen mit waffeln sozusagen
die der westen am ende hier gelassen hat
usa das sind die sachen mit denen diese
menschen hier 20 jahre bekämpft wurden
und jetzt gehört das ganze land noch
einmal wir haben gerade gesagt dass sie
natürlich die scharia einführen werden
sie haben aber gleichzeitig versprochen
dass die wirtschaftliche situation sich
schon bald verbessern wird wir haben
versprochen das ist insgesamt besser
wird als unser neuen regierung das ist
auch das ziel schneller
weil wir sehen gerade die menschen die
in der kamera lachen und hinter dir
jemand schwer bewaffnet mit ernsten
blick wie bewertest du überhaupt die
sicherheitslage derzeit im land du bist
ja quer durchs land gereist von
usbekistan rhein gereist dann über 40
stunden in richtung kabul gefahren du
hast es für halbe land wir sehen wie
bewertest du die gesamte situation
derzeit in afghanistan vor allem für die
menschen die jetzt an dieser ja so
genannten party in diesem
unabhängigkeitstag nicht teilnehmen den
nicht zum feiern zumute ist
noch vertritt sie ja also ich habe
gestern diejenigen besuchen können die
eben dich verstecken von diesen menschen
wo ich mich gerade versammelt habe die
unbedingte deutschland wollen sie sagen
sie müssen jetzt verschwinden sonst
werden sie getötet wenn man mit dem
taliban darüber spricht und sie fragt
was ist mit der rache was wird passieren
dafür wiederholen so landrat ich das ist
eine amnestie gibt für diejenigen für
die ortskräfte für all diejenigen die
für den westen gearbeitet haben das ist
eine amnestie gibt also dass ihnen
nichts passiert aber das glauben die
menschen natürlich nicht die sich in
diesem versteck aufhalten falls liegt ja
ich habe gestern die man treffen können
und jetzt steht die verbindung zu paul
kurz still aber das sind auch wenn das
bild einen moment still steht so
wahnsinnig bewegende und berührende
bilder die uns paul damit bringt aktuell
aus der nähe von kabul der wohl
gefährlichsten hauptstadt der welt
aktuell in der paul vor anderthalb tagen
am abend angekommen ist und jetzt
berichtet er uns heute von dieser ja so
heißt es
unabhängigkeitsfeier der taliban wir
sind jetzt zurück im bewegtbild paul
nehmen uns nochmal mit einfachen die
situation ja bei also wir sehen hier das
der mikrofon verschiedene
anführer der taliban zu den massen
sprechen wir sehen aus ganz afghanistan
menschen die sich versammelt haben es
mit immer wiederholt dass es jetzt eine
neue regierung gibt schon in wenigen
tagen möglicherweise sie haben auch hier
noch einmal betonen dass es eine
amnestie geben soll es diejenigen die
gesagt dass die frage glaubwürdig das
ist und sie haben gesagt dass es
veränderungen geben die es in sachen
sicherheit wirtschaft recht und
natürlich haben sie angekündigt dass die
scharia jetzt gilt es hören wir mal rein
[Musik]
also dass in slogans verrät gerade mein
übersetzer gegen die internationalen
truppen also gegen diejenigen die sich
lange gekämpft haben die genau dann muss
ich noch einmal genau übersetzt zu
machen aber sind ist die menschen freuen
sich sie sind glücklich dass die us
truppen abgezogen
wahnsinnsbilder paul du siehst wir sind
hier sprachlos hier in chile werden wir
sehen was da bei dir im hintergrund
passiert hat sprechen taliban-führer bei
einem unabhängigkeitstag so wie sie es
nennen feiern den abzug der westlichen
truppen feiern ihren sieg war so von den
männern durch einen übersetzer auch
dabei die dort sind die dort um dich
herumsitzen die ja mit neugierigen augen
fasst dann auch immer wieder über die in
die kamera schauen und sich anschauen
was sagen diese männer wie äußern die
sich die sind vermutlich in einer
einziges schauen wie wir es jetzt ja auf
diese art party aussehen müssen die also
ist patricia die männer wenn man mit
ihnen spricht die sagen endlich seid ihr
weg ihr deutschen seid die amerikaner
sind weg und eigentlich haben wir gar
nichts gegen euch es ging immer nur um
die internationalen truppen und das ist
die klare anlage ab jetzt habt ihr uns
in ruhe zu lassen wir wollen mit euch
diplomatische beziehungen haben aber ins
innere von afghanistan dürft ihr euch
nicht mehr einmischen sonst werden wir
wieder zu schlagen das ist die garantin
die wollen also auf der einen seite will
man beziehungen aber man kann sich das
so vorstellen man stelle sich vor eben
die scharia angewendet wenn ist ein
kritische stimmen gebe zum beispiel aus
dem westen ich das möchte man sich aus
witten und man möchte hier habe sorgen
dass am ende eben das bild was die seit
vielen jahrzehnten wollen dass sie
recherchierten islamische scharia
einführen und ein vorbote dafür was wir
heute sehen sind dass es keine frauen
gibt die hier sitzen es gibt auch keine
mädchen diese sitzen sondern
ausschließlich männer das sind tausende
die sich hier aus dem gesamten aus dem
erster gesamten ja
[Musik]